look at all the propaganda posters you
talk about branding and messaging and
storytelling going back to World War I
and even Beyond but certainly World War
I and World War II look at the posters
that we did Germany did and Japan did to
demonize the enemy it was a person it
wasn't a poster that said capitalism is
bad or Nazism is bad it was this
grinning evil looking Hitler that we had
in those posters so I think I think it's
going to be harder to
um activate people if it's just a
concept we need to personalize the enemy
too yeah and I think it's a it's a it's
a really interesting question of what is
where should the energy be placed right
in in demonizing the enemy and fighting
or or sort of creating and accelerating
towards solutions that can Elevate trust
well we need both we need both we need
both and I think one is defensive and
one is offensive
right elevating trust
is offensive is defensive I should say
it is like depend on which which way you
look at it right but there's a lot of
interest I would call it offensive
actually because you're you're creating
new tools for for Humanity and you're
not defending you're not just trying to
put up defense walls against something
that is inevitably coming and is growing
exponentially
[Music]
fast Adam it's so good to have you here
pleasure to be here thanks for having me
great to see you it's really good to see
you um talking about messaging branding
persuasion communication I'd like to
start with something that you pointed to
in a in an article you wrote Yesterday
by philosopher Hannah
aret the result of a consistent and
total substitution of Lies for factual
truth is not that the LIE will now be
accepted as truth and truth be defamed
lie but the sense by which we take our
bearings in the real world and the
category of Truth Versus Falsehood is
among the mental means to this end is
being destroyed right great quote isn't
it means a lot yeah what does it mean to
you she uh just I'll say first she was
she wrote on totalitarianism she was a
great thinker and uh maybe you heard the
phrase um about ikan the banality of
evil she covered the ikan trial for the
New Yorker and looked at him and
compared just his little Meek kind of
boring presence and the enormity of the
crimes that he did and as a bureaucrat
which she was and the Cog in the wheel
of the Nazi machine she described it as
the banality of evil not the grandiosity
of evil but the banality of evil and
that became a big a big phrase became a
meme before we called it a meme but
anyway back to your question about that
quote I think what's important about
that quote is that she recognizes
that the nature of Truth and our
conception of Truth and belief in truth
is really how we situate ourselves in
the world it's not just a matter of
somebody's telling me a lie or I can't
believe that person it's our our our
existence really and the way we um
integrate with and react to reality is
very much based on what we can believe
and what we don't believe and that's how
totalitarian governments operate they
control the reality they control the
entire personal ecosystem in our
personal space and I think that that's
really what she was referring to not an
individual bit of information
misinformation obviously she wrote that
before um social media but she
anticipated the risk of being
destabilized by a lack of conviction in
what's real and what isn't real right
and so so maybe even one step backwards
let's talk a bit about the power of of
of what you see in here on the on a very
fundamental level you attribute a lot of
a lot of impact to the information we
see in here and how that shapes our our
our mental thinking process our our
psychological
well-being I think often I like to look
at things through the lens of evolution
and behavioral psychology because you
know our brains have been hardwired over
Millennia thousands and thousands of
years before technology
existed and the way we survived and the
way our genes um proliferated is because
we were able to identify patterns see
what was happening in the outside world
and adapt and react and we heard the
sound of an animal and we knew that we
couldn't uh we were in danger we were at
risk the people that didn't know that
didn't survive so we are now here on
this planet at this moment because we
are Adept at picking up signals and then
processing them and then
reacting now all of a sudden and by the
way our I think something like 80% of
our brains are devoted to visual
processing wow so that's Evolution so
now all of a sudden we're faced with the
world where everything that we've been
hard wi understand and react to is being
threatened all the all the cues and the
patterns that let us evolve because we
understood the outside world and we
reacted to it and now being threatened
that is really precedented in the
history of humankind right and and so
what what does this all mean then you
know if we're going back to what what
what Hannah wrote and talking about the
you know how we've been hardwired to
experience this as part of our life what
what would it mean to be in a world in
which we don't we can distinguish it
means it means a couple of things it
means number one that um we're going to
be destabilized and we're going to be
threatened and um in that piece that I
wrote which you mentioned I made the
analogy to children who grow up with
abusive or lying parents and in the most
vulnerable formative years they they
learn that they can't trust the world
around them and they grow into
dysfunctional adults with substance
abuse problems with mental problems and
other issues because as children they
didn't know who to trust now we are as
adults and all of a sudden we're being
infantilized as children because we
don't know who to trust so to your
question it means we're going to have to
rapidly learn new behaviors I mean we're
capable of learning it's not like we are
programmed and that's it but we have to
learn new behaviors and we need the
systems uh and the media and others to
help us learn those new behaviors
because as you know and there's been a
lot of Behavioral work on it it's hard
to learn a new Behavior it's very hard
and we default back to our fast brain
response and to learn a new behavior and
to interrupt the fast brain response our
slow brain or cortex has to kick in that
requires a lot of work it's like when
you're training your brain to think
differently about food um you've got to
be hyperconscious and Hyper Vigilant and
people are not always that way
particularly in today's add world so
it's doable to your point but it's going
to require a lot of rewiring right
and I think that there's a lot of people
well I don't know if it's a lot but
there are people who are on the camp
that says we shouldn't be learning we
don't need to be learning new behaviors
we need to fight the emergence of of a
certain technology or of a certain
progression or an evolution for our
digital expectations and sort of go back
to to to the old processes do you think
that's feasible because you immediately
go to talking about rapidly um embracing
new behaviors and adapting
well you know what you're doing
righteously is to innovate technology
that will
Upstream do whatever is possible today
and tomorrow and the next day to
identify deep FES and challenges to
veracity so I don't think it's an and or
an or I should say I think it's an and I
think we need Clarity and we need people
like you who are saying wait a minute
we've got to stop this in its tracks but
we also need people not to believe that
they are without responsibility too we
got to beat in the we got to beat in the
middle here and and you know I actually
I I do see our role as as accelerators
into this sort of new Behavior that's
being adapted because being able to
identify the Deep fakes doesn't stop the
Deep fakes and and in fact I'm you know
I consider myself a techno Optimist I'm
right I I love AI I'm I'm enamored by
the incredible creative things that
people are creating and big big parts of
me are are truly excited about this new
world we're going into where there's
this sort of the coexistence of of
authentic content that represents
reality and there's a million realities
in front of us except that I think that
in order for us to enjoy this
coexistence we need the tools to be able
to distinguish between the two and to
create somehow a new level of trust in
what is real I totally agree with that
and that's an interesting challenge yeah
I'm a techno Optimist too when we can't
be doing the work we're doing if we were
just dystopian which is not to say we
don't recognize what the downside risks
is are but I think the word you just
used distinguish is a is key here I mean
because that's as human beings as
conscious sentient human beings that's
what we do every day we distinguish we
distinguish ethically between right and
wrong we distinguish between people who
are trying to mislead us and people who
we can trust and we've got good skills
to distinguish we need technology to
help us be even sharper and more refined
at at distinguishing but I think that is
really what separate look it's it's not
just you me primates can distinguish
right primates use tools monkeys are
using tools so um again we're we're this
is evolution at work and it's
interesting that it's happening so fast
I think I absolutely agree I I do think
it's Evolution at work except that
Evolution I think tends to to to be
centered around our senses you know the
evolution of our brain the evolution of
our sight and and hearing and taste and
smell but here I think we're we're
evolving in a new sense which now all of
a sudden is technology and technology is
not only a layer between us and and sort
of the world it's it almost we need to
embrace parts of technology to augment
almost like a seven I agree but but
evolution is also immune our immune
systems right and that's a whole other
conversation but our immune systems
evolve basically to help us recognize
and defend against pathogens and other
and other um material that's going to
make us sick and we've talked about this
a lot Michael you know there is a really
strong analogy between in fact it's on
the website between immunity and
sharpening our immune systems
physiologically and what we're doing
what you're doing with the immune system
of the world really in terms of the
pathogen of misinformation absolutely so
tell me a little bit about about about
branding and messaging know let's go
back to the basics because a lot of I
think what's happening with with AI
generated content and you know this
series is about the role that artificial
intelligence is going to play in our new
found human experiences and we're
talking about learning to adapt to new
behaviors in these human experiences a
lot of it and especially those that come
with AI generated content is all about
the messaging that they bring and how
they impact our perception of reality so
tell me a little bit about your own
relationship with communication and
branding it's a close intimate
relationship so look I think branding in
its simplest
form is
storytelling and again back to Evolution
we are we are wired to um going back to
sitting around the campfire to listen to
stories and share stories and connect
with stories the first line of Joan
Diddy in The White Album is we tell
ourselves stories in order to live and
it's true so one of the things that I
don't think we're giving enough paying
enough attention to is and the Russians
did is the way in which synthetic media
misinformation deep fakes can fit into
existing mental uh Frameworks and then
reinforce what we believe so the risk of
deep fakes is
multiple but one of them is that and
this is a branding issue and and a
messaging story if you believe believe
that Joe Biden is the worst person in
the world and that he is scile and
daughtering and can't put two sentences
together on a podcast then or in a news
conference and then if you see a deep
fake that shows him falling off the
plane or ex doing something that he
never
did why would you believe that because
it fits your existing perception that
Joe Biden is UN able to fulfill his
duties so that's what the Russians did a
lot back in the day when they first
realized that they want to destabilize
and break down trust and they will tell
you if if you know because people have
gone public who were involved in this
yeah they kind of wanted to elect Trump
but what they really wanted to do is
break down faith in the system so if you
think that to my earli point if you
think that the system is broken as
flawed it's corrupt and then you see
manufactured synthetic imagery about
that it will reinforce it what we call
in behavioral psychology the the
availability heris or the confirmation
bias which you know about we've talked
about that so I don't think you're going
to see deep faes are less risky when
from a brand and storytelling point of
view when it comes to getting people to
change their point of view it's more I
think effective in getting people to
double down on their point of view which
by the way is what marketing is often
about you know it's there's a there's a
factoid and it's true that the people
who pay most attention to advertising
for a car are the people who just bought
the car H because they want to be
confirmed that they did the right thing
and that ties ex together with just what
we're talking about now so
true I think that's such an such an
interesting distinction that because you
know they talk a lot about in in social
media and how it polarizes part of the
polarization is that it enforces your
existing beliefs by having by showing
you content that that enforces that and
you're taking it now to the to the Deep
fake space and how deep fakes are just
another are an evolutionary way if I was
yeah exactly if I was going if I was if
somebody said to me hey create a deep
fake campaign that's going to support
Trump that's what I would do I would
basically reinforce and double down on
every every bias every belief that
people have about what's wrong with
Biden not just physically in terms of
his policies giving money away all of
that stuff um and it could be very very
effective it doesn't necessarily have to
be doing an impersonation of Biden it
could be telling a madeup story about
somebody who you know is a millionaire
who's getting back money on from the
government stimulus program or paying
off their student debt well and and it
could be a look likee impersonation of
Biden which is indistinguishable and you
want to believe that it's true because
it enforces your framework your your
mental framework of of of what reality
is or or I do let's say let's say I have
somebody who says yeah I you know I make
$300,000 a year and I got my money I got
my student Deb paid off thank you Joe
Biden and then you do a def fake of
Biden where he
says I am happy to to give money back to
everybody who has student debt whether
they owe a whether they're millionaires
or not made up right but the think about
that commercial I just kind of put
together the ju deposition of a fake
story about a rich guy who got his debt
paid off and Biden confirming that
that's pretty powerful that that's
extremely powerful and I think what
potentially could be even more powerful
here is that I imagine you know a lot of
times we think about deep fakes and and
you know we think about their their
ability to persuade people to to think a
certain way and I think that the
distinction he made that that may be
true and it and may or may not be true
but but their extreme Effectiveness in
enforcing existing beliefs you can it
takes polarization to another level and
I think a lot of these times in these
closed communities H you may have
situations in which you have deep fakes
enforcing existing beliefs and PE other
people aren't even aware of it because
we don't see each other's Fe we're in
the filter
bubble exactly and that's correct and I
don't see the Deep fake that's going out
to somebody who lives in Absolut
Oklahoma and the other thing we're
seeing the contrary we can we can see
the the ones who are surfacing up or
trying to persuade the other parties and
those are the ones making the headlines
but not the ones that are enforcing
existing belief right the ones making
the headlines are the ones that the
media choose to amplify but those are of
tiny tiny fraction just the tip of the
iceberg about of all the messages going
out there trying to ch change the way we
think well just one other point to make
Michael is again back to
psychology human beings don't like
contradictions and they don't like loose
ends and they don't like subtlety for
that matter which is why we're so
polarized we're kind of dug in so that's
another cognitive bias that the Deep
fake Community will use which is if you
are insecure about something you are
stressed if you can olve it you feel
better the different neurotransmitters
are released so what you want to do with
deep fakes from a messaging and branding
point of view is eliminate
contradictions and reinforce beliefs so
people can go off and be happy
so looking looking a little bit ahead
and uh given that we're both uh
optimists into the ahead because we're
both working on on solutions that will
help us do that rapid adaptation and and
learn these new key behaviors I think
one of the key questions here is how how
do you generate trust one of the things
that I'm particularly optimistic about
is that we've spent the last several
years many many years I think even
before I was born in slowly eroding
trust in digital content and information
perhaps when I can imagine when the
first writing came out into the world
several thousand years ago immediately
the the first impression is wow okay now
we can transmit information from one
place to another and then a week later
it's like oh wait but now we have this
problem of lying on it on on written
paper right and then with the cameras Oh
now we can capture reality and then all
of a sudden you have tools like
Photoshop starting to emerge and people
and are like uh oh wait actually not
everything is reality but but hopefully
a good portion now the tides are
switching and it almost feels to me like
we've also in the 2016 elections in the
last few years there's been sort of this
Universal understanding that we're in a
pro a state of misinformation and it's
on an exponential rise and it feels to
me that we're at an inflection point
with generative Ai and deep fakes where
this is now catapulting to the sky and
it potentially can also serve as an
opportunity to create new infrastructure
for systems of Trust on information
which never existed before there's no
need for it perhaps need but there
wasn't enough maybe Market incentive
right to to double down on it and invest
potentially hundreds of millions of
dollars to create it well you know go
back to the Gutenberg Bible right and um
go back to the printing press rather um
the Bible was the first thing that was
printed the fact is that the cost was so
high that the ability to distort was
economically not feasible mhm and then
you mentioned Photoshop and all the and
and the ability to make Kim Kardashian
look you know 20 pounds thinner and and
all that the tools became
cheaper and the risks became greater but
I don't think but the awareness lag
behind so I think we are to your point
at an inflection point where we see a
convergence between the availability of
the tools the commodification of the
tools and the
recognition that you need to be or alert
and
also Society is recognizing just like
during the the uh pandemic that we need
technology to rise up to this moment and
help us and almost rescue us and I think
it's very analogous to the vaccine
development You Know M mRNA vaccines
were around for a long time and in fact
the founders were often dismissed nobody
believed that they were going to be
effective and then the moment happened
and then they changed the course of the
SARS K2 epidemic and I think that what
we're going to see with technology and
why I think we're both techno techno
optimists is that we can rise to the
moment and identify and Mark and block
deep face maybe not 100% because nothing
in this world is 100% but by doing what
you're doing you're you're raising
awareness and then helping people
close the last mile on their own I think
that um talking a little bit about Co
and and and taking some insights from
there would actually be very very useful
for us so walk me back a little bit to
to what happened in Co and how how
you've seen the public perception
centered around it because I think it's
an important pivotal moment in society
where you have sort of this crisis
moment that sort of the floor you know
opened up and now there was a lot of
uncertainty
a l Hyer I was running to the theark
toilet paper and my friends in Israel
couldn't get eggs right um and and we
and and there was a lot of things
happening in order to create to create
trust and and Elevate reality and Truth
what what happened there in your
eyes in terms of vac in terms of the
vaccine or in general I think more even
in the public perception I mean how did
we what was sort of the the
communication the persuasion the levels
of
uncertainty well the levels of
uncertainty and stress were were Cosmic
right as you said people were um
suddenly thrust into a world that they
had never thought of or really
anticipated despite the warnings of a
lot of epidemiologist but to me what was
two things are interesting about that
one is the relative speed with which
people adapted right like I would have
there were really no riots people
storming the supermarket to get their
toilet paper and their eggs and if I had
said to you before what do you think
would happen socially what kind of
social upheaval would there have been
you might have painted a much more
dismal bleer picture than actually
happened so I think the ability of human
beings to adapt to change and to be part
of a social fabric was pretty remarkable
now of course we're on the other side of
it and people are looking was that by
the way was that because we had quick
Solutions in place or because we have
human nature no we didn't have quick
Solutions we didn't have enough
protective PPC for the hospitals and we
had tents outside of hospitals in in us
not in Israel as much but tents out in
front of hospitals people were dying
because they didn't have enough um
medical attention so no there I don't
think it was that I think it
was the society for a moment kind of
came together a brief moment because
then everything kind of got polarized
but there was a moment when we realized
hey we're at uncharted waters and maybe
we are part of a human family and
everybody was vulnerable and it for a
moment it knocked down a lot of the
divisions because we realized that the
person being inovated in the hospital
was sitting who was a construction
worker was next to the Harvard professor
and they're both struggling for breath
so I think there was a moment when our
common Humanity was there and then
didn't last that long it was like after
9/11 in the US too we saw that right
there was a moment of coming together
but in terms of what does that mean now
for what we're talking about in terms of
Truth and deep fakes and by the way I do
think that it's important though to also
remember that um you know that during
covid a lot of you know we were at home
we were is we were in isolation and a
lot of real world processes came to a
pause or sometimes to a halt and so I
think that a lot of what we've also seen
is sort of people going back into their
own into their communities and and the
amount of energy that was happening in
the dayto day was less and so I think
potentially that was also a contributor
to the fact that it felt like it was
that our adaptation to this crisis
moment was a little bit more was was it
was less severe than what we expected
you're right it was also we were locked
down with our families and when people
are with their families right it
triggers certain emotions and certain
warmth and a certain sense of what's
important in life that doesn't exist as
much when we're out and out and about
and we're playing the game of life with
all the int I think people being with
their I mean I I can't tell you how many
people said to me you know there was
something and it's a lot of been a lot
of press too despite everything lockdown
was not bad I liked lockdown I got to
play board games with my family we got
to have real conversations at dinner I
felt like I was reestablishing
connections that had been lost in our
dayto to day lives which is a re which
is a real interesting phenomenon so so
going back to taking The Optimist to
taking the optimism that we've
experienced in our adaptation to the
crisis moment what what is this then how
do you translate that to to what we can
forese up
ahead I think the risk of deep fakes is
like again metaphor of the of the virus
is universal yeah so I think the
universality of risk and the destruction
of truth that comes from the
universality of risk has the potential
to bring people
together and it's always been true with
cyber crime which I know is a big part
of the underlying technology of what
you're doing but somehow you know if you
have a Visa or a MasterCard and you're
pii is stolen I don't
necessarily think that I'm bonded
emotionally somehow to somebody else's
information was stolen but I think when
we're threatened by Deep fakes and what
we believe is now subject to attack it
could as a techno Optimist have the
potential to bring people together
against a common foe yeah um and the foe
in this case is a kind of ambiguous is
not a it's not a person right it's a
it's a thing it's a movement it's a
technology it's a concept it's a layered
it's a layered foe there is a person
there is a person behind it and then
it's a concept but one of the things
that I think will help help fight it is
to personalize it it's hard to you know
go back and look at all the propaganda
posters you talk about branding and
messaging and storytelling going back to
World War I and even Beyond but
certainly World War I and World War II
look at the posters that we did Germany
did and Japan did to demonize the enemy
it was a person it wasn't a poster that
said capitalism is bad or naziism is bad
it was this grinning evil looking Hitler
that we had in those posters so I think
I think it's going to be harder to um
activate people if it's just a concept
we need to personalize the enemy too
yeah and I think it's a it's a it's a
really interesting question of what is
where should the energy be placed right
in in demonizing the enemy and fighting
or or sort of creating and accelerating
towards solutions that can Elevate trust
well we need both we need both we need
both and I think one is defensive and
one is offensive
right elevating trust
is offensive is defensive I should say
it is like depends on which way you look
at it right but there's a lot of
interest I would call it offensive
actually because you're you're creating
new tools for for Humanity and you're
not defending you're not just trying to
put up defense walls against something
that is inevitably coming and is growing
exponentially fast you're right it's
like in cyber security what was the
first uh Innovation a firewall mhm but
then it
became became very clear very fast that
you can't build a firewall that these
Mal words going to get into your network
and then you need all sorts of other
sophisticated tools and effectively what
we've built from a cyber security
ecosystem is a layer of technology which
is very proactive and it very
proactively scans and proactively
defends and proactively creates new
mechanisms to empower employees
cesos Executives to have visibility in
monitoring as to what's happening which
is very different from from the world we
were in I think 20 30 years ago and
actually see you know deep fakes and and
deep fakes as a cyber security threat in
very much a similar light the very
initial reaction is whoa let's let's
very quickly build up some firewalls
correct so that we can just stop because
they're incoming they're coming in once
we've gotten that first layer in now
it's a question of okay how do we
actually Empower people to now live
their day-to-day knowing that these
things are coming in and some of them
are getting through some of them are not
but how do we now live in coexistence
right because we still want to be in the
internet we want to trust digital media
we want to interact with digital media
and so I think that I think coexistence
is the exact is the exact term of import
and it gets back to the other word I
picked up that you used distinguish
distinguish and coexist have to work in
harmony look the iPhone is
supposedly very effective at keeping out
viruses like although the other just the
other day there was a story about um
interesting piece of malware that Apple
announced that was able to Target
high-profile individuals but the point
is most people when they look at their
iPhone don't worry about a virus MH but
when they get a text message that is
clearly not from your ups and you know
it's fishing or
smishing um your brain is now been
activated to the risk so that is I think
the question to your point about
coexistence how do we not live in a
state of Siege and constantly worrying
because if we do that we'll just block
it out and continue versus how do we
smartly remain aware without um being
paralyzed and that's complicated for the
for people to do um the other you
know there's a theory about it's sort of
the opposite side of adverse selection
which is you know when you wear a seat
belt you feel protected people drive
faster that's the data this data that
shows that they think they're protected
people who are taking interesting people
taking statins will have a stake because
oh I could have that c or that Porter
House now I'm taking my uh lipid T so we
also as people who are helping to shape
the conversation can't make people too
overconfident nor could we make them too
dependent it's kind of like bringing up
children you know you can't totally be a
helicopter parent and scare the crap out
of them because they won't be healthy
adults but you can't let them cross the
street either and go to school if
they're 5 years old by themselves so you
it's sort of without paternal liing the
conversation it it is
complicated to find the right goldilock
solution here and potentially I think
that uh you know I it sounds like seed
belts are are more of a Band-Aid and you
know then you have autopilot cars you
know that's the solution you still want
to empower people to drive and to be
able to get from one place to another
you need these quick Solutions in place
because if somebody gets into a crash
without a seat Bel they die so you need
also quick solutions for example in with
deep figs but then long-term Solutions
need to be ones that actually perhaps
Empower people to do what they do best
and we also have to we have to also make
sure that if 1% of deep fakes are not
recognized which is possible
right or one half of 1% that people
don't discount the whole thing because
there's something in Psychology called
the zero risk
bias and what that means is if we don't
if we are not convinced that 100% of the
problem is solved then we don't change
Behavior so for example if you say to
somebody um if you quit
smoking the risk of you getting lung
cancer is reduced by 90% well I still
this 10% chance I'm not going to quit
smoking a lot of data about the zero
risk bias so we have to make sure also
that we don't overpromise about what we
can do right now it'll get better and
better and better and that's why we need
to create a Cooperative situation with
the with with with the user also
because once people hear of ah look they
this supposedly was this this system
supposedly blocked every defect but this
one got through therefore the whole
edifice doesn't work will fall apart
again it's called the zero risk bias and
it's a hard thing to fight
M you know so when you look at actually
you know being able to adapt to to a new
world in which AI generated content is
infused with with authentic content I
think it touches on on many different
verticals and I think one of the one of
the areas in which this category is
maturing is that we starting to
understand that you know digital media
is a connector that is being used as an
infrastructure amongst every different
amongst every verticle from social media
to news to Enterprises to Legal
evidence and so the ability and the
tools to recreate trust and Empower
people to trust what they've seen here
perhaps are different also for every
vertical and it could be that some of
them are similar and some of them are
different I totally agree but I also
think that there are some universalities
about how to build trust that there was
this vertical specific like you say and
there's also things that cut across so
during the during the pandemic when it
was hard to get a lot of people
vaccinated in the
beginning there were all these
commercials I'm sure you remember about
why it's important with all these
celebrities but the most effective tool
to get people people vaccinated were
churches and local trusted leaders who
people believed in Beyond just the big
National megaphone
of TV and digital
advertising so I think if we're going to
conceptualize about how to build trust
which is your point we need to find
analogues to that who are the local
institutions local individuals across
these verticals that
we can leverage and activate to be the
ambassadors of trust building what else
creates
trust transparency and honesty it gets
back to the
1% if you overpromise and you're that
you're able to um solve all the problems
then trust will erode and that's what
the vaccine deniers did very well they
found two people out of 20 million
who had menstrual problems who had other
problems and that's oh oh look what
happened to her and the Brain goes there
it's the availability herisa and then
trust vaporizes you
know when airplanes crash as
Unfortunately they have been or have
problems people start driving it's true
it's been true for years of course the
risk of driving is exponentially greater
than the risk of it doesn't matter
what's in your brain that last headline
about the you're blown open so we have
to to build we have to not overpromise
and give people Frameworks that they can
accept and find trusted uh individuals
to deliver th to deliver those messages
too also who are the
people behind the companies you who are
creating this world of trust people need
to put a face on a belief system so I
may believe you more than I believe um a
company speaking that doesn't the
faceless company speaking mhm so how
important is it do you think that
there's ultimately an some some
attachment to personas that I think it's
important why yeah
because again when I'll go back to
evolutionary biology not to be boring
but when when um somebody said to my an
cestors come this way because the
Predator is that way or don't eat that
mushroom because it's going to kill you
we transfer trust to that individual we
are wired to transfer trust to
individuals not to Concepts not to um uh
ideas but to
individuals and I think we're seeing
that in business and politics now you
know for what you know musk for all his
complications
is somebody that people look to and say
look I build four companies five
companies and we're fascinated it's part
of Storytelling like when we you know
it's part of fairy tales and it's part
of nursery rhymes and it's part of how
we were brought up to be fascinated by
what individuals have to say and believe
in individuals and I think it's social
media has Amplified that more than ever
why are influencers changing marketing
and able to sell products because I'm
transferring my trust it's a trust it's
a trust exchange right and that's what
we need to build a trust exchange I
think it's an import it's a really
interesting comparison to look at that
that social media and short form videos
the one of the very first things that
they did was that they created this
influencer economy that's right and a
creater economy too yeah exactly but it
was but all of a sudden we saw that
there's a whole something that I I don't
know if many marketers thought
understood that before but there's this
whole ecosystem of influencers which it
turns out that the people who buy the
product if they see somebody they trust
even if they only have 10,000
followers the number doesn't matter look
I have a friend who a pilot and he
watches and he's very suspicious guy he
doesn't you know he doesn't follow a lot
of traditional media but there are user
groups of Pilots talking about this
avionic equipment or this technology and
he follow and you it's clear that they
know what the [__] they're talking about
yeah and they are passionate about it
and they're knowledgeable and he buys
those products and you know
exponentially multiply that by 10,000
absolutely that's what we're happy with
well that is an interesting buy product
of the polarization it's a different
kind of polarization it's a different
kind of filter bubble but it's a good
one I think because basically you a
marketers are not speaking from the
mount from the Pinnacle they're finding
influencers and there are all these
platforms as you know that find
influencers they're letting the
influencers deliver a trusted message
and it works right and I think that's
also one of the one of the potential
pitfalls of of of deep fakes right is
that they can take those same
influencers and and take other stances
or or amplify opinions that that are not
true for them I think you're absolutely
right and I think we call them the Nano
influencers the mini influencers in
these little groups
in a way you could argue that that is
one of the highest risks of deep fakes
right because it's it's easy to spot and
take down potentially deep fake of Joe
Biden exactly and Tom Hanks but it's a
little harder to create infrastructure
that can identify and and create a layer
of transparency or potentially take down
a deep fake of a nano influencer
absolutely there look there are hundreds
of thousands of of coffee afficionados
and and coffee groups and coffee
influencers
and tens of millions of dollars in
advertising revenue and Commercial
Revenue are attributable to that kind of
influencer how easy would it be right to
create out of the blue a new coffee
influencer who looks real who speaks
this and by the way one brand could do
that to bring down another brand too
right or one brand could hire a
surrogate to do that I mean it gets
really layered right and so you know
obviously we're we're in the AI
Revolution and this is what and and the
adoption is just growing on a day-to-day
basis and it's getting better by better
by the minute at this point um with
Market incentives just pushing it to a
super Evolution I think probably what
that means is that over the next few
years we'll get to a point where AI
generated content is completely infused
in society I think if you ask some
people they'll say that that's already
the case today I believe that's already
the case today but I think that we will
experience the tithe shifting that much
more of the media we experience will be
AI generated probably over the next 12
to 24 months um and and because we're
techno optimists and because we chose to
spend our time working on on solutions
for this and solutions to adapt right I
don't again I don't think it's a problem
that AI is emerging I think it's it just
requires fast adaptation agre I agree
with that how how does this new world
look like as we successfully create new
trust and so what does that actually
look like for example in news right
three years down the line we've created
a new system of trust in a way that even
is better than the trust that we had
yesterday look I'm sure that in three
years or five we'll have ai generated
newscasters we'll have ai generated
Steven
[Music]
coars and I think Society will accept
that as long as there's some clarity
around what
has been synthetically created and what
hasn't so
for like saying like just the other day
maybe you read this Dove Dove Beauty
said we're not going to use AI but it
was a it was a marketing stunt it purely
was because it's like saying in
1955 I'm not going to use videotape I
mean Saturday Night Live it's not
[__] live it's recorded earlier so I
mean we've been using technology
forever really to create a synthetic
world to some degree or another right
now we can create a totally synthetic
world or a partially synthetic world
with much more Fidelity and speed and at
lower costs than ever before this is
here now we need tools to help people
understand what they want to know and
when they want to know it but it's going
to be inevitable that there'll be some I
don't know if watermarking is going to
be the answer probably not
but again getting back to sort of a a
health
metaphor we know exactly who you are by
your
DNA and there's no mistaking it what
will be the DNA equivalent the the the
uh Gene mapping equivalent of digital
media it's kind of what you're working
on right and I think it'll happen you
might be able to look at I'm sure like
we talk about the person is real the dog
running across the screen is not real
whatever the the hybridization of
synthetic media is but there will be a
way to measure that just like you could
measure your DNA or your proteomics or
whatever else and say okay this piece of
this this this digital media is this
this person is real the dog is not real
and and
decompositon I think there needs to be
some um ability to use technology to
break down and deconstruct
media and I think the tools eventually
will be in everybody's hand I mean look
how look at the cost of of Gene mapping
how it's gone down through the Human
Genome Project maybe there needs to be a
artificial um or synthetic media
equivalent of the Human Genome
Project just kind of an interesting
thought
experiment you know I think that
ultimately it's um know you I we don't
know what what what's the if there's a
one solution to this and probably not
and and I'm a believer that there's no
bullet bulletproof solution to to
decomposing media what I do think though
is that you know it's very similar to
this notion of fact checking correct you
know we've been talking about you know
factchecking efforts and I and I haven't
seen yet a model a sustainable model for
for being able to fact check things well
information in terms of the content now
the question that that deep fakes are
asking is a little bit different but
very similar and I think a much more
manageable question it's a question of
asking is this a representation of
reality right we're we're asking is this
Visual and auditory information that I'm
perceiving not if it's truth but is this
real does this represent a version of
reality which is which is a
representative of the physical
world and and and I think that when we
talk about the transp parency reports
and the context it comes back to this
question because anybody can still lie
and it's not necessarily it's a
philosophical question really I don't
know if you ever read the essay Walter
Benjamin's essay art and the mechanical
means of reproduction very very famous
essay he wrote before he died escaping
the
Nazis um going over the mountains um
from France to Spain but he talked about
he
anticipated what we're talking about now
which is what is the difference between
the original rembrand and a
representation of the rembrand when you
put on your Apple Pro Vision whatever
it's called and you're in Paris it's a
represent it's a representation of Paris
you feel like you're in Paris part of
your brain probably shuts off and you
convince yourself that you are like when
you were in a dream state you kind of
convince yourself you are there um now
then you have a then what about a few
ulate the that AR and VR with deep fakes
it's another layer of complexity right
yeah absolutely but it's about
representation I agree yeah and I think
that we are building now the not just
the clarity but the ecosystem is is
coming together to build a new
infrastructure for for how to decompose
what what represents reality and what
what doesn't and there's many many
layers to this there's the AI detection
layer there's the water marking and
Providence layer there's the testimonial
layer from the identities that are
actually represented in the media and I
think taking as a metaphor the cyber
security ecosystem sort of looking at as
a multi- signal you know a system that
comes together and for every piece of
media ask okay what signals do I have
and what story can I tell from I think
look you use it is infrastructure and
the infrastructure will be as complex as
it needs to be to solve a very complex
problem right you know I talked about
firewall the if you look at a landscape
of what cyber security was 25 years ago
it was a very simple diagrammatic view
right and now look how complex and
multi-layered cyber Securities it it's
you need an infrastructure and
effectively paoo networks I think came
out just a couple weeks ago in a very
big statement talking about the
consolidation and the platforma tization
of cyber security and they're
effectively coming and saying you you as
an organization you you can buy all
these end points solutions to protect
yourselves from the threat that you
perceive but in reality as long as we're
we're treating them as fragmented
signals then we can't tell the whole
story you raised a really interesting
issue and crowdstrike is doing the same
thing by compositing everything together
because you do see it is a dynamic
situation we kind of start off like with
a one solution like the firewall and
then it gets very complicated and you
have a lot of Point Solutions and in
cyber security then you had the sore the
op the the orchestration need because
you this ciso this Chief Information
Security Officer became so overwhelmed
with the tools needed a master tool to
run the individual tools and then you
realize wait a minute we're going to
start to kind of consolidate and bring
things together and we'll probably see
that same dynamic in in in synthetic
media and I think it it there's I think
it's a beautiful comparison because the
yes the the cyber security official
within the organization needs simplified
tools to manage it and that speaks to
their trust right can I can I enjoy the
work I'm doing can I be empowered to do
my work better and so you need to
consolidate right but I think part of it
which is even more important is the fact
that it it can lead to better insights
and it can actually lead to better
defense systems by being able to
synthesize the different signals that
are coming together so if if a big part
of the role of the ciso up until now was
to look at many different endpoint
Solutions and and sort of have this
dashboard this dashboard I think that a
big part of what is now possible
partially through AI as well and comp
and advanced computation is to be able
to synthesize all these sources to tell
a more a richer story a deeper story
absolutely the um you know the big
problem in cyber as you know is the
signal noise issue right and ai's
ability at speeds and Quantum Computing
is going to change that too massively to
be able to separate the signal from the
noise at a level of speed and accuracy
not possible before we need that in that
that's the same uh example that we can
apply to deep face also it's a signal
noise challenge absolutely and it's also
and and I think that when we now bring
it back to sort of the right the right
infrastructure and the right solutions
for deep fakes you know it's not just
about a a a the the provence from a
certain water marking it's not just
about the detection it's not just about
the testimonial it's really about the
richness of of the signals that you get
on the media and how rich of a story can
you tell and how do you do that at scale
how do you do that efficiently and how
do you tell that story in ways that the
stakeholders actually perceive and are
empowered by that story because telling
that story to a consumer that's watching
a Tik Tok video is very different right
than the story you're telling to a news
editor before they broadcast a media or
to a banker that's onboarding a kyc a a
customer now through their traditional
measures right that's gets back to what
I talked about before the trust exchange
we can't the user needs to believe that
b dance Tik Tock or whomever is the
platform has done whatever they need to
do within reason so that they could
watch that little video about somebody
putting on mascara and believe that it's
a real influencer not a synthetic
influencer and that's where the
transparency comes into I
think there will have to be an opening
cyber security maybe I'm wrong but what
I'm thinking in cyber security you kind
of the user never really knows what's
happening behind the curtain right now
there's no transparency there's just
we've you know JP Morgan has you know
industrial strength you know cyber
security maybe what we'll see here is a
more because it is visual right deakes
are visual maybe we will actually see
explainer videos and exciting videos
that help people understand how deep
fakes are identified and expunged I
would expect that to happen I think that
the fact that deep fakes naturally are
are occurring in a world that's Visual
and auditory right it stimulates our
senses yes it's not just another cyber
security piece of information that
stimulates just one part of our of our
that's correct that's exactly right then
it's it's very it's very likely and
makes sense that solution that the real
good Solutions here will need to also
stimulate
those same senses in order to help
contradict or explain what we see it's
not just going to be through a a score
it's not just going to be through color
that you actually will need to
experience parts of the media um with in
in different ways in what we and that
doesn't mean that every single person is
going to want to watch the 10minute
video definitely but the fact that it's
there absolutely matters you know when
people buy a piece of
Hardware 9 80% this is the big debate
with Google and they opt in opt out 80%
of people leave the factory settings
they don't change it right yeah that's
but you know that you can but you know
that you can exactly and you have trust
because you can and that was actually
that's been a big story between you know
Android and iOS for many years you know
the open system the closed system yes I
I'm curious how many users in Android
actually went in to change their
settings after they bought it but it's
very likely that many did not right but
they are proud to be a part of an open
system that they have the ability to do
that but you just said is super
important they're proud to be part of an
open system that's how
branding activates
self-identity and who you are is
expressed through and by the products
and services that you use and the
Android user and when you speak to them
they hate the app they hate Apple they
feel like they that apple is just is
just um creating an environment where
people are slaves to the iOS system and
that the the Android User is a free
independent thinker and they go their
own way and they're not Lemmings so yeah
our brand choices are very much
expressions of who we believe we are
maybe not Who We Are Who We believe We
are which is more important so Adam a
message to our team back at home uh
working extremely hard to uh keep
[Music]
going well I was going to ask what are
what are your main uh you know tips and
recommendations and
advice ER for us ER for me for for our
employees for for anybody in the
ecosystem that's working on on fighting
this problem so I'm I can't give you any
technical advice my prowess is limited
but I will say that when you're doing
your important engineering work and your
coding work and your deep fake detection
work have part of your brain think about
how would you explain this to your
grandmother right think about the
narrative and the storytelling part of
the Innovation and actually what might
happen is that the Simplicity of that
storytelling could actually lead to
better technology also because it's very
you know we have something it's called
the um
subtraction the addition preference and
the subtraction bias and that's why
products get too complicated because we
like we don't we it's
literally literally cognitive pain when
we simp when we move things away we like
to add we like to add we like to add so
that's my advice don't add for the sake
of adding add for the sake of efficacy
and make it simple and explainable no
matter how complicated is behind the
curtain Adam thank you so much thank you
for for joining me today thank you for
uh being part of clarity of course and
uh and for being a a very important part
of our journey and uh we have a lot of
work ahead of us hey thanks for having
me it's been a great conversation and
there will be more of them and it's it's
an exciting Dynamic environment so you
know we need people like you and your
team who are exciting and dynamic to
stay ahead thank you